an Ever greater number of people on an
Ever more fragile Planet as some parts
of the world experience bulging youth
populations 70 of India is below 35
years of age elsewhere the portion of
older people is soaring
population aging is very unprecedented
phenomenon in this video we'll examine
how different parts of the world are
dealing with the unique challenges of
demographic change we look at the
policies needed to ensure stability
so the future is bright depending on the
policies that are being made
um it's it's maybe dire if you know the
appropriate policies and the appropriate
actions are not actively pursued
and we'll look at what we can do to
secure both our economic and our
ecological future you know one of the
most impactful Eco actions we can take
individually is to choose to have one
less child that's all coming up on
business Beyond in November 2022 the
global population hit 8 billion it was a
significant numerical landmark and all
the more striking when you look at how
fast it was reached
in the past two centuries the number of
people on the planet has increased
eight-fold the momentum is expected to
continue for the next few decades
getting as close to 10 billion by 2050.
much of that growth reflects progress
improved Access to Health Care means
there's been a drop in infant mortality
and a rise in life expectancy
but it's also a challenge the planet
hasn't got any bigger and ensuring that
everyone has enough food a place to live
a job an access to Care on their age is
a mammoth task
one country where this is already
abundantly clear is India home to 1.4
billion people it's expected to overtake
China as the world's most populous
country in 2023
population growth has long been an issue
in India between 1975 and 77 the
government introduced a repressive
reproductive control program
it was an especially dark period of the
country's history over 6 million men
were sterilized in many cases against
their will some 2000 died from botched
operations
you very rightly mention the forcible
sterilization during what is called
emergency in 1975 to 77 two years where
people were forced to undergo
civilization even young people even
Bachelors you know because the
government had set some targets and they
were forcibly in poor and young people
unmarried people who were forced to go
undergoing sterilization today
population policy in India tends to be
the domain of individual states rather
than the national government but when it
comes to keeping family sizes down
coercion remains a tactic
the Northern State of uttar Pradesh is a
good case in point it's home to around
240 million people for context that's
about the same as Britain France Italy
and Spain combined
in 2021 it introduced a draft Bill to
push people to limit their children to
two under the proposal state employees
who agreed to undergo sterilization
would be offered Parks like promotions
and help buying a home
those with two children or more would be
barred from government jobs welfare
programs and from standing for election
Professor s.y curaci is the author of a
book called the population myth
he says the experience of other Indian
States shows coercive policies of this
kind have a particularly damaging impact
on women
because if I am a candidate foreign
so you know they started divorcing their
wives giving away their children in
adoption so it harmed the women and
children very much India's fertility
rate has dropped significantly over the
past few decades in 1960 the average
woman had six children today it's 2.1
but because of previously High rates the
current cohort of young people is big
seventy percent of India is below 35
years of age India is the youngest
country in that way the country of Youth
Christian League only five percent of
India's uh young population is
considered skilled skilled enough to be
the of use to the world and if we could
read 30 40 50 100 why not so we need to
focus on improving the quality of our
education another part of the world
facing the challenge of harnessing the
potential of its youth is Africa over 60
percent of the continents population is
under the age of 25.
and unlike in India the birth rate
remains very high the average African
woman will have four children in her
lifetime in Niger it's almost seven
the rapid growth of Africa's youth
population has led to a surge in the
number of people moving to cities
putting a huge strain on Urban
infrastructure and services
Cairo Kinshasa and Lagos are already
mega cities defined as a city with 10
million inhabitants or more by 2050 a
further seven will join the ranks
the city of Lagos in Nigeria has grown
at an astonishing rate from a few
hundred thousand in the 1950s to more
than 15 million today more than
two-thirds of people live in informal
settlements many of them in slums
we're one of Africa's fastest growing
city and so you can imagine the level of
contestation you know for resources for
um you know livelihoods for access to
services or access to the good things of
Life over half of the working population
of Lagos is employed in the informal
economy
taban lawrenson is a professor of urban
planning at Lagos University she says
authorities need to recognize the city's
informal labor
surrather than condemning people to the
margins of urban life or in fact
criminalizing the ways by which they
feed their families the important thing
or the right thing to do is to recognize
the agency that they bring to the table
she says this would ensure workers
rights are protected and crucially pull
a huge number of people into the tax
bracket when it comes to securing the
future of Africa's youth she says three
things are needed
the first would be education to
strengthen education so that
the young people have the skills to
operate in a global knowledge economy
the second will be opportunities
opportunities to grow to have jobs to be
Innovative to start businesses you know
to do what they want to do at you know
particularly for those who have capacity
who are entrepreneurial that is also
important and then the third will be to
ensure that there is an opportunity to
grow it's not enough to start off it's
also important to be able to scale up to
grow to expand as African leaders try to
figure out how to empower their huge
youth populations here in Europe the
demographic challenge is very different
as birth rates continue to decline many
countries are worried about how to
support their aging populations
at present one in five Europeans is over
the age of 65. by 2050 it will be closer
to one in three the portion of the very
old those over 80 will see an especially
large increase
at 1.4 children per woman Poland has one
of the lowest fertility rates in the EU
in the past few years it's actually seen
its population shrink
so
the Polish population has a very
specific structure so we have a huge
Baby Boom generation that was born in
1950s we just currently more or less
retired we had a baby boom generation in
1980s which is currently a part of the
it's more or less in the prime a but we
have very few people that enter the
labor market in the moment because
fertility in Poland
the client and remained law like in many
other European countries policy makers
in Poland are worried about how to pay
for the pensions and health care of its
elderly population
Poland's sex-dependent retirement age 60
for women and 65 for men makes this an
especially big problem so we indeed have
a problem of
low activity of older women and low
pensions of older women because the
pension formula taken into account both
accumulated contributions at life
expectancy life expectancy still
obviously is longer one obvious way of
boosting a population is by welcoming
immigration in recent years Poland's
Economic Development has proven a draw
for foreign workers in fact Poland in a
very short time
from attending country transformed into
receiving country so this is a new
phenomenon for Poland
which
was not indeed a result of specific
policy but rather the labor market needs
and activity of employers and that were
encouraging and inviting more and more
migrants to come to fulfill the
vacancies that they had
Russia's war in Ukraine has also led to
a large wave of migration with Millions
seeking Refuge elsewhere in Europe
researchers say it's too early to know
if this will cause demographic shifts in
the long term it all depends on how long
people are uh will stay
if ukrainians if if the Ukrainian war in
Ukraine uh stops uh and many people are
returning then the demographic impact of
uh the immigration of more than a
million ukrainians uh is uh in long-term
uh
try to close to zero in the absence of
wars and Health Care emergencies like
the covid-19 pandemic demographic Trends
are relatively easy to predict but often
they're not on the top of policy makers
agendas
when we think about politicians they
have very short perspective of four
years of
the regular term
and as a result
it's very difficult to prepare for the
demographic change because each
government thinks that you know it's not
something that we have to immediately
deal with and our Spectators can do that
as well
and at the end of the day we
find ourselves very frequently in a
circumstance that the
um are very difficult
speaking of taking the Long View one
rather sensitive topic that is not
easily talked about is what our
population growth is doing to the
long-term health of the planet
Robin Maynard is the director of a
charity called population matters he
himself has two children and says he
understands how awkward it can be to
talk about the impact family size has on
climate change
still he says the evidence is compelling
we know one of the most impactful Eco
actions we can take individually is to
choose to have one less child because
that will that will reduce uh greenhouse
gas emissions carbon emissions over the
lifetime of that child and potentially
that child's children much more so than
if we do all those other good things you
know changing our light bulbs to low
energy light bulbs not flying giving up
our car taking a vegan diet but it's 20
times more impactful and if you look at
the science if you look at the reports
whether it's by Lunt University in
Sweden or Oregon State University
there's really good evidence of that
his organization firmly opposes any form
of coercive policy like those we heard
about in India or the one child rule
China recently discarded to address its
aging population
but it does ask people especially in the
Richer world to consider the planet when
they make decisions around Family
Planning
it's a sad reality that when it comes to
climate change the poorest parts of the
world are both the most at risk and the
least responsible they're also the areas
of the world where birth rates are
highest the tragedy is that you know the
number of women who have that unmet need
for safe Modern Family Planning has
increased by about 40 million over the
past decade due to population growth
in Africa and Southeast Asia similarly
the number of girls out of school has
increased in Africa by about seven eight
million because of population growth
it's a bit sensitive because for many of
us a man's wealth or a man's number of
blessings are counted by the number of
children and so in some of the religious
settings and some of the cultures Family
Planning is overlooked or perhaps
frowned upon but that being said within
the medical
within the medical sector within the
health sector I beg your pardon
you know at least at the Primary
Healthcare level it is still being uh
there's advocacy and there's guidance if
you want it research has shown that the
single biggest factor that correlates
with a decline in birth rates is female
education access to contraception and
GDP per capita also play a role
as the literacy goes up number of
children go down across communities
and as the income goes up the number of
children goes down again across
community
since the beginning of this video more
than 4 500 babies will have been born
around the world
some will be blessed with abundance and
others will struggle
some will be born into vibrant
communities full of young people and
others will enter societies that are
aging fast
all will live on a planet that has never
before been home to so many people
and that wraps up this edition of
business Beyond I'd love to know what
the demographic challenges are in your
part of the world do let us know in the
comments and if you like what you see
here check out our business Beyond
playlist a good place to start would be
our recent video on the challenges
facing big Tech
until next time from me and the team
it's goodbye and take care